ces temps ci on parle beaucoup
d'électrification des transports et de
batteries au lithium tête parce que
lorsqu'on parle des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre au québec 45 % de nos
émissions viennent secteur des
transports et on nous dit qu'en
changeant nos véhicules pour des
véhicules électriques mais on pourrait
régler une bonne partie des problèmes
d'émission pour en parler on s'en va en
abitibi part que la mort il ya beaucoup
de projets de mines de lithium
l'électrification des transports
ça fait partie du grand chantier de la
transition énergétique
on se débarrasse des combustibles
fossiles pour réduire drastiquement nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre yo des
métaux stratégiques comme le lithium qui
peuvent servir à développer les
batteries et permettent éventuellement
une plus grande électrification de nos
transports plus de richesses - grs merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
on veut abandonner l'extraction du
pétrole mais la transition vers les
énergies renouvelables
ça vient avec une nouvelle forme
d'extraction les éoliennes les panneaux
solaires et les voitures électriques
carbure aux matières premières
[Musique]
faut bien sûr les métaux conventionnels
comme le fer et l'acier pour leur
construction il ya ensuite des dizaines
de produits miniers qui sont nécessaires
pour construire les composantes
technologiques comme les batteries on
les appelle les minéraux critique et
stratégiques
[Musique]
non
les experts s'entendent pour dire
qu'avec les besoins de la transition
énergétique
la demande pour les minéraux et les
métaux stratégiques sont multipliées par
cinq ça veut dire que d'une dépendance
au pétrole on passe à une dépendance aux
minéraux et aux métaux
[Musique]
le québec fonce à fond de train dans la
transition le gouvernement vise 1,5
million de voitures électriques sur noro
d'ici 2030 les composantes de
motorisation de véhicules électriques
nécessiterait six fois plus de minéraux
pour sa construction qu'un véhicule à
essence le québec participera à l'effort
de guerre pour trouver ces ressources
québec or des gisements importants
de minéraux critique nous annonce que le
gouvernement a l'intention d'extraire
ces gisements dans son plan de
valorisation des minéraux critique
québec a ciblé une dizaine de ressources
à fort potentiel sur son territoire mais
un métal est sur toutes les lèvres
lithium
[Musique]
le lithium c'est un métal vraiment
important pour la fabrication des
batteries lithium-ion qui vont servir à
stocker l'énergie de la transition
écologique sa demande elle devrait
bondir de 500% d'ici 2050
et
les plus grandes réserves mondiales se
trouve dans le triangle du lithium formé
par le chili l'argentine et la bolivie
la bons produits du lithium par
évaporation dans de grands déserts de
sel les salaires
mais ces points de production qui a
bonne presse et le cube beaucoup d
espace et consomment des quantités
astronomiques d'eau dans un
environnement désertique très fragile
le canada détient 3 % des ressources
mondiales de lithium au québec il ya une
demi douzaine de projets de mines à
l'étude
[Musique]
le lithium québécois seraient extrait du
sous-sol dans des mines à ciel ouvert
comme c'est le cas en australie
actuellement l'un des plus grands
producteurs de la planète
ces mines à ciel ouvert ne sont pas sans
conséquences il y a des montagnes de
résidus miniers des risques de
contamination le carburant brûlé pour
l'extraction l'énergie nécessaire pour
les procédés de raffinage il transporte
vers les transformateurs
en termes d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre pour 1 kg de lithium les mines à
ciel ouvert de strahl y produisent deux
à trois fois plus de ges que les mines
d'amérique du sud
québec marc telles que
l'hydroélectricité va permettre de
verdir l'industrie minière parce qu'on
va éviter qu'on utilise par exemple
bistrot carbone pour produire de
l'énergie je préfère et de loin que l'on
puisse exploiter seul itium là au québec
dans des conditions environnementales
qui soit avec des hauts standards on est
en train de lancer un grand chantier qui
va faire partie de l'histoire du québec
un chantier qui va être bon pour la
planète mais un chantier qui va aussi
changer la face de notre économie
le gouvernement voit grand très grand on
répète que le lithium va devenir un
exemple de valeur ajoutée de
l'extraction jusqu'au recyclage mais
dans le projet actuel il ya plusieurs
éléments manquants
la transformation du lithium brut en
batterie est une chaîne de production
complexe il y à l'extraction le
raffinage la construction des
composantes technologiques celles des
cellules de batterie puis l'assemblage
le québec n'est pas encore impliqué dans
toutes ses étapes et la compétition à
des années d'absence
la chine produit près de 80% des
batteries de l'industrie automobile elle
domine le monde de la transformation et
l'amérique du nord dépend de la chine
pour ses batteries le canada et les
etats-unis ont signé un accord de
collaboration pour limiter leur
dépendance à l'asie
si la tendance se maintient le lithium
du québec sera un produit destiné à
l'exportation pour être transformée
ailleurs jusqu'à ce que toutes les
étapes de la chaîne de production soient
réalisés ici ce qui prendra encore des
années
en attendant la province développe sa
filière avec quelques joueurs notamment
dans les domaines des véhicules
commerciaux et celui du recyclage
on vient juste d'arriver à val d'or ici
a déjà plusieurs compagnies qui
s'activent pour répondre aux besoins la
transition énergétique quand les bons
l'an prochain épisode la ruée vers le
lithium ça représente beaucoup de
craintes et pas juste des opportunités
soudainement les mines sont vertes parce
que on veut alimenter les voitures
électriques alors que c'est pas le corps
n'est pas une solution verte aussi
figure hic ici ça va être explosé ça va
être un trou puis devant une montagne de
déchets miniers
seul plein